This is Joel. He runs a coaching and
course business that teaches people how
to basically use credit cards to get
sweet vacations. [music]
Problem is that he's dependent on one
platform. If that platform goes away,
his business could die basically
overnight. I'm Alex Hormozi, founder of
acquisition.com, which helps businesses
scale. And so, let's meet Joel.
Hey Alex. I'm Joel McDonald, founder of
Just Get Out of Town, also known as
JGoode. Tell me about the business. So,
we help travelers turn everyday expenses
into multiple bucket list vacations
every year. Our largest audience is
retirees,
empty nesters, and business owners.
>> I would not have guessed that. That is
really interesting. Okay. The way we
help them is through something we call
travel hedging,
>> [music]
>> not travel hacking. We differentiate
ourselves there. This allows travelers
to stretch their vacation budgets three
to 10 times farther.
>> So, what's the difference between
hacking and hedging?
>> Travel hacking basically requires that
you churn 10 to 20 credit cards a year,
and that's why it has such a bad
association.
>> Uh Travel hedging is [music] choosing
the two or three best cards for your
individual spending profile,
and learning how to effectively use
them.
>> So, what's the current state of the
business?
>> Our trailing 12-month average is 6.4
million. Got a 1.9 profit margin. That's
about a 30% profit margin. ROAS is 4.5
to 1.
And then our
LTV to CAC is a very skinny 1.4 to 1.
We'd like to change that.
>> Yeah. So, what do you want to have
happen?
>> We've got about 12,000 clients that we
put through either our mini memberships
or our high-ticket coaching program. Our
goal is to have 10,000 more in the next
year. We'd like to diversify our
advertising channels and start to
include a lot more affiliate
partnerships and charities. Uh I've got
a goal of a million donated through
partnerships with charities in the next
year.
>> Oh, cool. In order to do that, we're
going to need to double our revenue. So,
now tell me about how you get customers.
Basically, like I said, it's a book
funnel, and 85% of our customers come
from buying the book.
>> I'm familiar with book funnels.
Another 10% comes from conferences,
meetups, guest podcasting. We're beefing
that up. We're trying to diversify our
channels.
>> [music]
>> And then right now, affiliates and
charity partnerships are kind of in
their infancy, but we do get about 5% of
customers there. So, what are the
problems right now? So, our biggest
problem right now, single channel
advertising. Uh we're heavily dependent,
like I said, about 85% on Meta.
We were we're kind of hitting a ceiling
at 100 grand a month. Yeah. I spent 150
grand last month and it got 10% extra
book sales. It is a loss leader. It's
currently taking us about 6 months to
break even, even with the the back end.
>> Yeah, second problem. A lot of
skepticism in this industry, largely
because we are associated with travel
hacking. A lot of people assume this is
a lot of trouble to save 10 or 20%. The
actual savings when you travel the J Go
Way is more like 70 to 90%. When people
plan a trip,
the odds of them getting a great deal on
that trip, and that they've already
painted themselves into a corner, say if
they want to go to Italy in June, the
odds of that being a good deal is kind
of like placing a chip on roulette.
Yeah. Most times it's going to be very
expensive. Every once in a while, like 1
in 20 times, they get lucky. The J Go
Way of travel is you find the good
deals, there are thousands of them out
there. You plan your vacation around
them, and it's like placing a chip on
the roulette table after the marble
drops.
>> Anything else that you have? So, knowing
that you probably have more points than
you know what to do with, but not enough
time to figure out what to do with them,
we put a little itinerary together that
includes a Singapore suite Ah.
>> that typically goes for 5 to 10 grand,
apartment that's another 5 to 10,000
dollar flight one way. And we basically
put an itinerary around the world that
would normally cost uh about 70,000
dollars for the five countries that we
found, and we showed you how to do it on
points for 1,800 bucks out of pocket.
Love this for us. So, basically, we're
going to send you from Vegas to San
Francisco to Singapore to Abu Dhabi,
then to London, and back home through
Mexico City.
>> images. And all of these are first-class
flights that would normally costed
either $70,000
or 7 million points, and we put them
together for about a million points.
It's a clear savings property. You have
to spend money
in order to
sit you have to spend money to save
money type thing. What percentage of
your sales right now are outbound versus
inbound? Right now, so we just
implemented some aggressive outbound
like within the past month. It's been
probably 60/40. 60% inbound,
40% outbound. We'd like to really ramp
that up. That'll probably be a central
feature of what we're talking about.
What do you want to have happen with the
business? Do you want to double it? Do
you want to sell the business? Or do you
just want to make money with it? I have
zero interest in selling this business.
Great. Well, then this makes it way
easier. I'd just like to impact twice as
many people's lives. So now that we've
gone through Joel's business, I'm going
to work through core areas where he's
stuck and what we can do to fix them.
And for each area, I'll break down the
exact principles and tactics Joel can
use to scale, which are likely going to
apply to your business as well. So let's
get started with number one, which is
being clear whether Joel has a
supply-constrained business or
demand-constrained business. I have a
bunch of ideas. You want to come on this
side and we'll utilize this brand new
beautiful paper desk that my team made
for me. Very excited. Let's do it.
>> [laughter]
>> My first trash question that I'm always
thinking through is this a supply- or
demand-constrained business? So this is
demand-constrained business. Like you
can handle more customers. So
there's two ways we can think about
this. So if we have this from a decision
tree perspective, right? It's like,
okay. So this is demand-constrained
business. Got it. So in order to fix
demand, we can go new channel. I know
that you're considering doing like the
second channels. I feel like there's a
lot more that you can work on the
existing one by like a lot. Just because
the nature of this offer is so broad.
This is the type of offer that can
probably scale to like 100,000 plus a
day in spend. It's like, okay, so we
have new channel.
We have lower CAC,
which underneath of this we can do
through CRO, so conversion optimization.
We can do this with better creative.
Or
offer.
So this is this is me just kind of
sharing how I'm thinking through this.
So we can get that or we can just spend
more, all right? Which is always a fun
one. But given the fact that you said
you've had these constraints on whenever
you do spend more, you you like quickly
hit a wall, which is fairly common, then
it's going to probably be a combination
of one of these three things. I'm
basically going to focus on those pieces
because these are basically the three
things that are going to unlock that. So
right off the bat with better, where are
you getting your UGC? So user user
generated content. Because you have the
most visual type of product. The image
that I saw was just like you and the
team. My god, people take pictures on
their vacations and I'm feel like your
groups probably have crazy, you know,
them in front of the Taj Mahal and you
know, whatever else. I feel like if you
have that kind of like a TikTok style,
like check out this trip that I just
booked for under X, I think that would
destroy.
So like video user generated content.
Yeah, like selfie style, like you I mean
I'm sure you probably get all these like
think about these Instagram pages that
just show like trips and like all these
kind of like hacks and stuff. And a lot
of them have like 1 million, 2 million
plus and like they're very active, like
super engaged. I would model
those style videos. Michael, can you
just try and pull up a good travel page
on Instagram? So this style just like
this.
Okay.
>> With your real like and that's a real
person. You can tell. She's not some
model. It's like a real person.
>> [music]
>> And if just had a pinned thing on the
top that was like I did all this for
under $1,800, I think it will work
really well. And just run all of it,
test it all. And I mean again, we can
run it organically and test
>> is so visual. This is so visual and
people watch these so they can just
vicariously live through it and it's
like you don't have to live through
this, you can do this.
A plane far. Okay, that's compelling.
The highest point of leverage that I
think in this business and I'm going to
change some back end stuff too, but like
if you unlock the UGC
loop, this thing will flourish. And so I
think are you on TikTok?
Uh embarrassingly
low following but yeah.
>> Okay. There's some businesses that it's
tougher. If I have a tax savings
business, it's like maybe I'll have a
business and they're talking about it's
tax savings. It's not very visual,
right? Maybe you get some emotional
about the story and things like that.
That's how the angle you'd have to take
there. This is so visual. What we need
to do is number one, we need to
incentivize people to post the reels
inside of the story. And when they do
that, they get to unlock some sort of
checklist that you hold back and people
are like, how do I get access to that?
It's like, oh, post a a montage
of your trip that you were able to do in
under 60 seconds.
And here's how you do it. And you can
show them how to how to put it together.
And I think a lot of people would want
to do that. And you already probably
have a a ton of them anyways. Right. But
just ask for permission to use them and
then you can get the and basically in
exchange for permission, they get this
extra training or they get this extra
thing. I think that what will unlock
this is a decentralized content machine.
So instead of you trying to be like,
okay, we have to go make more ads. It's
like every week we have 20, 30 videos
that are coming from our community of
the trips that they were able to take.
And every week we just blast off 30
videos up there and we see where the
winners are. And then boom, once we have
the winners, then we just juice them and
then we try to cut them a bunch of
different ways. Okay. So the second
thing, so the UGC loop, right?
I'll go into more detail in a sec, but
that's kind of like the the big thing
number one. Second one is something I
call kaleidoscope. But basically
I know you have one piece of creative.
Do you want to pull it up, Michael? The
the highest converting one of all time.
So one of the interesting thing we can
do here is like so this image, it's like
there's 20 ways to Sunday we can we can
do this. So like you had the AI versions
of me that you did in all those. I want
you to take this image and then AI-ify a
bunch of different versions of this.
It's like, okay, how do I make this
black and white? How do I do with a
sepia filter? We could take this and put
it into AI and say make a 3-second video
of this image, which it would then just
make a 3-second video of it even though
it's just an image. Let's do a
cartoonized version and let's do cartoon
in this version and Ghibli and let's do
it like cuz right now that's trending
and so that will give you 20-30
variations of whenever you do have your
winner, blast the hell out of how many
more slices and angles that you can take
on it. In terms of the copy,
what I found in scaling like a campaigns
is that when you do have copy that wins,
you don't need to change it nearly as
often as you think. So like when we ran
The School Games all last year and
pushed it really really hard,
we had one
version of the copy that we ran for 6
months and then a second version of the
copy that we ran for three.
In a different company that we own, we
spend gosh,
a couple hundred thousand a day
and after 5 years,
there's three hooks.
There's three like when you find the
winners, you just run them. And so I
think so part of it is just like putting
your mind at risk of like, what do we
need to do this different? Like, no, you
found your winner. So now we just need
to like create different verse So the
creative on the other hand, that changes
all the time. But with the copy and the
messaging, it's like we just leave that.
If it's if it's working, it's like you
can just keep using that over and over
and again. But I do think this UGC loop
will be really big and then once we have
the winners, we kaleidoscope the hell
out of them.
Which is like how to which is like AI,
we have filters
that we can do. We have you know,
remakes, which is
can I Sorry. It's okay. Remake. Can we
take this um
video and then just re-film it? Cuz
these are a lot of these are going to be
video-based. And so it's interesting
about video versus static is that
statics work better for a lot of
businesses because they suck at video,
not because video doesn't work. But good
video beats images. Yeah, good video
beats images, but images beat bad
videos. And so most people are like,
"Oh, statics work like we can't get
videos to work, only statics work." It's
just cuz the videos aren't good. And
it's the same thing as people who make
content and like, "Oh, content doesn't
work." It's like, no, good content
works, but bad doesn't. Do you make
shorts or anything like that? Very
painful and slow growth, but yeah. You
need to just get one
hyper-caffeinated
uh 20-year-old who lives and is
brain-rotted Gen Z. Um see I see I'm
using I'm using this I'm using the
slang, right? Who just really is native.
They're plugged in to the platforms
because they'll be able to look
immediately at your stuff and be like,
"Oh, this one's not working." It's like,
"Okay, the hooks off. Like, you're not
using trending audio. You're trying to
make these look professional, but they
just need to be like iPhone selfie style
and we can use something like a pinned
comment on the top of the video."
There's so many like meme versions of
this. It's like, "You can travel around
the world for less than $1,000. Prove me
wrong." And then it's like and then
you'd have troll city
right? Underneath of it. Like, there's
so many different contextual like
trending things that are happening right
now. I would say that the number one
biggest thing that's limiting the
business is better creative. So,
typically when there's a cap, sometimes
it's a money cap, which is like, "We
just can't afford to spend more." And
I'll cover that in a second. But like,
the creative unlock
is usually why someone gets limited.
We've scaled to $10,000 a day, whatever
it is. And it's like, "Okay, so $10,000
a day is all we can spend
based on how good this creative is."
Right. And so, the easiest cuz I know
you come from an ad background. So, if
you're familiar with the Old Spice
commercial,
guy on the horse,
>> Mhm.
my theoretical view of the world is that
if you have a product that everyone
could buy, then there is one ad that is
good enough that could convert everyone.
So, that ad took Old Spice from a small
player in the men's body wash into the
majority of the market with one
campaign. That campaign literally took
the entire market for them.
And it's because it was so good that it
could convert everyone. Typically, the
limits are just that as if you think
about how Facebook or Meta or spends,
it's like they're going to go to the
most interested people first cuz you're
optimizing for conversions. And they'll
be like, "Okay, these are probably a
little bit less interested, but still
kind of adjacent." And then this is like
your CPA starts going up. Okay, now
there's this way bigger market over
here. And then as soon as you hit you
try to break through this wall, your CPA
goes up because the new creative's not
good enough. This UGC loop plus
20-year-old
uh crack
addict
Yeah, like that. Uh
>> [laughter]
>> uh, who lives on his phone or her phone,
uh, is probably the unlock here because
the best way to test this out is start
getting more aggressive with your
short-form content. They can make these
as obviously like organic posts and then
when you find your winners, just take
that same post, add a 5-second CTA at
the end, and then run that as an ad.
It crushes. It's a double dip because
you're posting content and they don't
have to waste any money and then when
one of crushes, you take that, boom,
post it and then run it.
So, that is the content
winners.
Also, I'm going to bet something
interesting here. This is Alex just
making a bet with no informed data.
Part of the reason that you have avatars
that are retirees and business owners is
that you are a retiree business owner
and they see your ads and also
Facebook's AI reads Susan the ad and
then displays the ads whether or not you
choose to target them based on who is
most likely to convert. And likeness is
one of the strongest predictors of
conversion. It doesn't take an AI genius
to be like, oh, we've got an Asian lady,
let's show this to Asian ladies because
Asian ladies are more likely to convert.
But they do through the algorithm so
it's not racial profiling. But if you
want to have more diversity in terms of
the types of customers, and this is also
like you think about this little loop
here, well, there's another one of these
that's for Asian ladies and another one
of these that's for Asian does men. And
so like you could probably get to kind
of saturation on each of the circles
even with your existing quality of
creative by just having a diversity of
avatars in the ads themselves. [music]
And so even though we're we could still
target the exact same audience, but the
algorithm will go target subject of the
Yes.
Cuz they're the most likely to convert
and they're the most likely that you'll
keep spending cuz it's converting.
Right. So, I'm going to write a bunch of
these down and then we're going to just
prioritize which one is the most likely.
But AI avatars right now are just about
good enough to be used.
And so you can have these kind of like
TikTokified
AI videos that are 15, 30 seconds of
like guys you won't believe it. I just
went around the world for under $1,200.
And the craziest thing is it didn't
objection number one, objection number
two, objection number three. And the
best part is I got it with this book and
I found it on a random ad. Totally
changed my life.
That's it. And they go straight to the
book funnel.
Mhm. I think that'll crush it. All of
this means we don't have to do all of
that other stuff. More of More and
better first if [music] we can. It's
just the nature of what you sell is so
visual. And people naturally take lots
of pictures. They want to share food and
travel. This is super visual. Tons of
people post about this stuff. Travel,
tons of people post about this stuff.
And I would look at the top travel
pages, look at the most viral content
they have, and model that for my ads.
Seven hidden gems that you've never
heard of before. And it's it shows these
like crazy montages. And those things
get like gazillions of views. All we
have to do is just weave the fact that
we have a pin. How do you see the seven
gems for under $1,000? Huh. Okay. Right.
Just we just have to just layer a filter
of like our offer in front of it. And I
think it'll I think I think I think you
have so much creative like if this is
the creative that's been running the
business,
there's so much room. I think it looks
authentic. But again, this is where I
think the UGC loop will be big. [music]
So one is you can use it with AI
avatars, you don't even have to ask for
them. But I think the UGC loop is like
probably the faster, easier, immediate
thing that you can do without having to
learn, you know, new stuff. I think that
this is really the front-end stuff. Like
this is
>> [music]
>> how do we lower CAC with just better
creative? So this gives us more from the
customers. This expands and multiplies
that even more. This gives us a content
loop that the 20-year-old crack addict
is going to be able
to make by modeling um
travel
pages.
Real quick, I'm going to show you the
exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish I've now done multiple
times and so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
head count increases that you need to
get through and I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business what the constraint feels like
like what are the symptoms of it when
you're going through it and then what
steps we actually took to graduate and
we've done this across software physical
products uh service businesses brick and
mortar all of this and it works and it's
my gift to you it's absolutely free and
so the link's in the description but you
just go acquisition.com road map just
enter your info and it'll spit it right
back to you all free. The meat of this
is still going to be the sales team so
the fact that you started last month I
think is encouraging. I do think that we
can improve dialer pick up rates.
What's the benefit of the annual call?
We want to make them help them get as
much out of the book. For the people who
don't qualify like if they spend less
than 5,000 a year they just aren't going
to have the muscle memory to learn
[music] these strategies. And so when
you're saying when you said the $5,000
thing you're saying if they spend 5,000
a year on their vacations
>> [music]
>> that's too small. Uh on yeah on travel
in general yeah. Okay per year.
Interesting. Okay. Does it have anything
to do with their credit card spend?
Yes those are the two most important
factors. So
So Also 5,000 a month. So remember when
I was asking at the very beginning like
are there are there specific factors
that qualify the avatar?
So if those are the two factors that are
most important for the sale then those
are the two things that I would want to
weave into the funnel that we could get.
So that way it's like if your team's
going to make the outbound dials and
your dialer probably can't score leads
or should be you know prioritizing the
leads then it's like we'll then we're
going to start with all the people who
are spending over 5,000 on their credit
card and then if 5,000 a year on their
vacations then it's like they're two for
two call those first and if it's a one
out of two call them second and zeros
it's like maybe we'll get to them if
we're bored.
So I think lead score
which is [music] then add
credit card spend and what's the other
one? Oh and then um vacation spend
to uh opt-in.
All right. One of the things that you
brought up was that the big list of
excuses that come up when you do the
pitches.
So, one of the things that I want to do
is we need to call it out before they
do.
So, on the sales call, I want to
basically
front-load all of our damaging
admissions.
Because you said it's too good to be
true.
And when you even offer this too good to
be true, you make it less good. So that
it's more believable. That sounds
counterintuitive. No, I mean we have to
do this, but it's like
our testimonials are often accused of
being fake.
>> Yeah. Generated AI. Sure. Too good to be
true. How old are you?
53. Yeah, you could be like, "Listen,
I'm 53. I don't even know how to work
AI."
>> [laughter]
>> Like these are real. No, but what I
would do with the damaging admissions
piece is say, "Listen, before I tell you
about the good, let me tell you about
the bad." And then I would just start
listing off all the things that suck
about this. It's like, "Listen, if you
want to only go on a specific day per
year,
it's not going to work for you. If
that's a problem, then like I want to
tell you that these are some of the
issues. If you want to go to top-shelf
places,
that we're good.
So, you can have what you want, just not
when you want. Mhm. And so that's the
trade. Now, if you're at a different
point in your life where you're like,
you know, I can take off whenever I
want, they don't mind if I take 2 weeks
in the middle of September versus the
middle of, you know, October or June, to
your point with Italy, you can
backpedal. It's almost like selling off
the back of it like, "Hey, if you That's
a problem for you, then this isn't going
to work." So it's like telling them all
the reasons it's not going to work up
front so that they're like, "Okay." So
then they can self-qualify. "Okay, I
could do that." Yeah. Versus "I refuse
to do that."
>> There's no way. It's too good to
believe. There's tons of other things
that suck about this. So let me tell you
about the things that suck. No, but the
thing is is that after you put all that
damaging admissions, so now when I tell
you what's good about it, you're going
to believe me.
But we have to I think you front-load
You want to take all the wind out of
their sails
and give them all of the reasons that
And then oh, you can weave in over comes
obviously, but you can do it from the
position of like, "Here's all the
reasons it won't work." But a lot of
people are like, "Oh, I don't mind
that." They're self-qualifying
because everybody still wants the
benefit. They just don't believe it.
They want it. They just don't believe
it. So, damaging emissions front-loaded.
We went through all of this, but I'm
going to simplify this into really just
two steps.
If that works for you. That sounds
great. I'm the master of
overcomplicating things.
>> [laughter]
>> I think big picture this right here
is thing number one. And I'm actually
just going to go this way.
Dialer, lead scoring, and I think you
need to increase your number of sales
people.
If we added this all up, we've got call
it 250 book sales a day. And then you
said you have 40 a month who joined the
$99 thing? A free a week. Well, we're
averaging about 600-700 a month. Okay,
700 a month. So, divided by 30 is 20-ish
per day and then book which is free with
shipping, right?
>> [music]
>> Something like that, I'm guessing. And
then Facebook group you said was 1,500
per month?
Yeah, 1,000 to 1,500.
>> Okay. So, we got 30 here. 30 new
Facebook members, we probably get 10% of
them who give a phone number. Okay. We
could just make it required if we wanted
to. And I think the reason they would do
it is because you said we include a free
travel assessment.
So, I think that's the nugget that we
give. And I think you do that for both
of these. But here, I'm just going to
just use rough math here. I'll be able
to put a little bit of But we have about
300 prospects per day that are coming in
the funnel. If you have 300,
I would probably be thinking like
gosh, you're going to need a bigger
team. Like if you really want to work
the leads, you'll probably need
six guys with a power dialer. Their KPI
should be like $300 a day each. And you
can use something called a parallel
dialer. What it does is it calls 10
numbers at once for each of them. You
have 5% pick up rates. So,
that you definitely need something like
this. But let's just say two people pick
up here. It'll automatically connect
this per one of them with that person
and one person this person. So,
basically the bigger the team, the more
better it works. [music]
>> That would be the answer, right? Cuz
it'll just roll to Exactly. And so, now
you just have massive amounts of dials
that are happening. And what you do is
you're maximizing talk time. Instead of
them just spending a lot of time just
waiting for a connection, they're going
to be like connected. And so, the
efficiency seems also going to go up by
a lot. And I think you can actually work
these leads cuz I think that the two
doubles, you probably have more than one
double in the business.
This is a
multi X unlock.
And this is a multi X unlock.
And I don't think there's anything else
you have to do.
And I think these two things, the nice
thing is that like they all will work
off of what your existing spend is.
But this will drive down CAC. All this.
This will also drive down CAC. So, your
LTV to CAC ratio will improve, so will
profitability. But then what it'll do,
and the main long-term benefit, is that
it'll break you through this barrier
into this much bigger pool.
Mhm. And then you'll be able to continue
to spend.
And scale.
Yeah, and that's something that I've
written off. But I started the company
for this bigger pool. Yeah. Started the
company because I was broke. Yes. I I
had no business traveling, but I
discovered it and
it was only by getting past assumptions.
Yeah. And I can't advertise to them. I'm
advertising to these people. Yeah. Cuz
they pay the bills. But I'd love to
impact
them. [snorts]
Yeah. And I think
>> This This solved that problem.
Yes. You have a demand constrained
business.
So, these are the paths. You know, we
can spend more, which we tried. New
channel, little too hard for right now
in my opinion. Can we lower cost to
acquire? Yes. We're going to do that
through better creative, conversion
optimization. We could have tweaked the
off The offer's already converting, so I
don't really want to mess with that.
[music] These are the two angles that we
attacked it from. This is the ad side.
This is the conversion side. Love it.
Rock and roll. Easy.
Pleasure.
>> Thanks, Alex.
>> Yeah, yeah. So, if you enjoyed this
episode with Joel and want to see how
I'd approach scaling a different
business, you can check this out.